[Music]
in living food news submitted by me loud
loves JK a restaurant schools the man
who shared a video of a worm in his food
a restaurant that called the Asian
restaurant Lee what do you so that one's
yourself man hey that's a pot of the
dish man don't give the secret recipe
away if he ordered worms and yeah that's
[ __ ] up
no but this this worm is a parasite oh
my god
mm-hmm it's a parasitic roundworm I mean
parasites come and go that's life
that's you that's how you got so you
gonna be ready much that's a fortune
cookie open it parasites come and go
that's life well thank you and the
person's like we're still giving you a
berating like but that's life yes this
took place in New Jersey and his family
they were all of a sudden they turn from
Asian to Italian in my head it was like
a Chinese I just thought New Jersey
Chinese people they went Italian
restaurant pizza joint stubborn dude
what worm in the food and then they
don't they don't say sorry they blame
them for [ __ ] exposing them that's so
Chinese you do a Chinese Jersey accent
hey why you expose my worm and the food
[Laughter]
yeah so they were eating at this seafood
place this seafood restaurant when they
found the girlfriend of this whole story
that he found this war I'm crawling out
of the codfish now I'm gonna show all my
[ __ ] guy that they post it on
Facebook how did they even see that tag
the restaurant and they actually pay
attention then why didn't they [ __ ]
tell the restaurant you [ __ ] no so
they did the restaurant took care of it
they caught the whole meal and they were
just like oh that's why it's fixed it
yeah but then the people I posted it
they were like well we wanted to let
other people know no they wanted Fame
they wanted the thumb you want to like
yep they already got fixed you don't
want Fame Casey that's why I'm here you
know what that means I would actually go
eat here you know why cuz it tells me
that they use fresh seafood it's not
frozen yeah but that's why the worm is
alive there are practices in place that
tell you they tell you how to prepare
the fish so they do kill the parasitic
worms so they are saying that tells me
they don't [ __ ] overcook the fish
yeah am i right there's no blanch or
some [ __ ] they have to keep it frozen at
a certain temperature to kill but they
don't freeze that's what I like about
these people they should be one though
but that's that the start of the video
parasites come and go That's Life that's
life yeah that's actually in the article
that's a theme stated on this video not
all parasites are created equal
did you know we have parasites in our
eyebrows we have parasites spider
we have parasites in our gut took a
little worm dude like in our gut in our
butt in our skin I'm nothing my buddy
said that's not what Nicky said well
yeah Nicky my boy sometimes that's what
she said are you gonna play I'm gonna
play it can you play it we didn't play
it I mean I do want to hear no I don't
want to hear you
fish with the water I'm not so Michael
let's hear it let's hear it for you but
Wow I'll tell you about my butt blaster
that part ended it's been worn out I
want to see that fresh work years of me
flipping that looks like my little
puppies worm when they freaking barked
on my bed oh my [ __ ] god
worms are one of those things though I
feel pretty national that's a huge worm
dad they pay attention like if I'm in
conversation scarfing down food I would
not see that they mighta ate a few you
know that was probably the one that got
away I wonder if it's one of those worms
that can come inside your body and [ __ ]
you up
or it's like one of those worms that are
just kidding [ __ ] you up they just
dissolve in your [ __ ] you just you just
use it as protein shoo the [ __ ] out of
it yeah it does
I read the article welcome yo did you
hear what he said he said he's a div and
then I just finished his sentence not
knowing what I would say my I'm sorry
what happened
welcome to it no [ __ ] you guys I'm sorry
always
particle beam see oh my god case you're
so boring dude it's cool when you're
with us it's just us guys it man up KZ
come on let's go I gotta look out for my
chances tonight man come on I get it bro
[Music]
it's never tips fall it's always the
[ __ ] article writers all right thank
you
you know it's always me asking crazy ask
questions that you should obviously
don't know that answers to but I do it
anyway yeah who's gonna be like what
type of [ __ ] worm is that Tiffany it
she didn't [ __ ] worms got kneecaps
why don't you know this information [ __ ]
I'll tell you this though that [ __ ]
little worm gave me flashbacks when I
was a little kid I loved sleeping with
my puppy my new [ __ ] puppy right in
the middle of the night I woke up opened
up my blankets cuz I felt something wet
on my foot it was vomit
and a little squiggly worm just like
that [ __ ] and I was like yes I ran
over bang on my dad's door and it came
out there all like what the [ __ ] man and
he's like looking like and they're like
all right that's it
the dogs not sleeping in the room
anymore and any Tosca like what the
puppy needs me that's the reason why my
parents never let me sleep with animals
but look at look at us now we sleep with
all of our animals look at me now what
do you do good do you like to be man I
see why they told us not to sleep at
that and they're [ __ ] disgusting well
if you don't do the pets the right way
like if you if you're ever just like
like regular like having hood pets well
you're not getting deworm and doing all
that stuff then yeah they're gonna come
with all kind of the right way and then
like the mom either the puppies stay
with the mom for eight weeks you need a
deeper of all the shots of stuff and
you're better off do what L all about
this [ __ ] is like you look at this worm
in the food right and if Nicky was here
at nYSCI baked like that right just like
yeah so she
be doing that right but then at home
like at night I will watch our cat
Franklin eat my other cat's butt out
like [ __ ] just eating his [ __ ] and
tongue whatever and then they even seize
the [ __ ] and I'm not even [ __ ] you
two and a half minutes later this guy's
like [ __ ] kiss my mother she's
already I'm the one who should be going
[Applause]
she's kissing you know my dick and [ __ ]
that's how you get parasites disgusting
yeah damn okay but have you gotten sick
this year
no that's all that that's what I'm
saying that's why I don't think why
people I don't know why people are so
overprotective just [ __ ] you eat some
dirt sometime from time to time well
because then you have the [ __ ]
one-in-a-million case where the [ __ ]
dog licks his owner and then he gets
agitated everywhere muscat parasites are
part of life they come and go whatever
it is that's what we learns and bad ones
just like bacteria all parasites aren't
creative and that worm if we ate it I'm
pretty sure we would have grounded that
[ __ ] know what have been dead by
the time I hit our stomach so yeah
that's that's good if we bit that one
Ethel's dead they chew your food unless
it's those worms that [ __ ] happen and
they multiply that way that's like a
sushi restaurant made make here at one
time we are at the sushi restaurant and
this couple the sushi restaurant in this
couple used to talk about sushi we used
to go to this sushi restaurant all the
[ __ ] time all right and then one time
we saw a couple who had a problem with
their food there's like a hair in the
food and these guys the owners would not
having it
they were like absolutely not no refunds
you put that [ __ ] there like what the
[ __ ] and it was and it was it was one of
those things where you're like man I but
they're blond and in the hairs black no
they it was it looked like one of the
waitresses our ears like that but they
were fighting back they're fighting back
just like how bark right now he's just
like he looked at some parasites you
know I'm saying you could eat it it's
totally fun actually is nutritious
you better never want to open a
restaurant I don't I will sign dorama
get in trouble I'm the same person that
if I like see a fly and my thighs take
it out anything
Bartz restaurant would be a 5-star
restaurant with the F grading it will be
the Fertile it look like one I got good
ideas the way she cooks it's so
hilarious like you'll be barbecuing you
have like black charcoal hands and
you'll be [ __ ] using it all over and
then he'll be like hey babe you wanna
bite it so he has like a taco with carne
asada but his hands are covering the
charcoal my tacos rubbing all over the
tortillas yeah it's hilarious like I'll
still eat it I don't care you know I
probably would too
yeah then you should be his [ __ ] baby
but knowing the process is not fun
that's like you guys stay inside I cook
it I put it in the little know-how the
magic happen yeah we are married i block
and I just tell myself everything's fine
I see all the steaks they just and I was
ever ate I probably dropped on the floor
I got a blow all the rocks ah can I put
it back on you just stop the [ __ ]
[ __ ] this question have I gotten sick
nope see strongman cooking gene that's
why it's just cuz it's Yvette's and it's
helping my immunity you've been building
your baby maybe he has because if you
put back here on everything you would be
building up your band so we're doing a
type that's youth yeah that's awesome
no you know what they wrote it started
it was really gross they're saying that
some people experience a tingling
sensation after or while they're eating
raw or undercooked fish or squid and
that's actually the warm moving in their
mouth or throat and then they can
actually that sometimes people can
extract the worm manually from their
mouth or cough up the warmth prevent
infection possible so if you ever eat
something it's kind of tingly in your
mouth that means there could be a
possible one
food ever [ __ ] what kind of food
should we avoid TIFF for this fish fish
or squid no sushi I mean that's fish I
like that [ __ ] [ __ ] it I'll take my
chance yeah I don't give up there's no
way by the time that worm hits my mouth
cuz I put so much [ __ ] wasabi on
sushi oh yeah that thing like it
disintegrates into a puff of smoke he's
[ __ ] puff a green smoke like a little
bit of wasabi smoke and he's gone
nowhere
[Music]
[Music]